i appreciated the fact that uh you know
recently on social media you started
engaging politically you were like
look this stuff's kind of important like
i i i know some of you
might not love everything but let's like
actually talk things out and like
you know be reasonable human beings
which you know i completely agree with
yes but it's difficult to get like
even people who agree with you if you're
just like here's this point
and even people would agree like yeah
because those cry baby lips blew it it's
like no no listen man
like this one point is good and then
tomorrow
trump's gonna have a middle p middle
east peace deal that you kind of gotta
say is okay
you can't just say it's bad you know
what i mean and it's so
like and uh even if someone agrees with
me with like just
rhetoric or negativity get the hell out
of here let's all talk
go yell at everybody else go yell at
trump's twitter feed
if you're here we're all gonna engage in
some talking and uh i took a little
break because it was really hard to have
a conversation
and i and i i have no hard feelings like
i have a heart of stone i don't give a
damn about anything what anyone says
about me if it's a good
if you zing me or make fun of me in a
good way like go lose some more matches
or something like you get me i get it
it's funny uh but i want it to be good
and entertaining and i want it to be
i want both well there should be more
than two signs but that's a whole other
conversation but
i wanted to be human beings engaging
and not just being so mad that they want
to go out in the streets or
wish death on somebody talking about
politics
um i don't disagree that we need a
different
level of dynamism in our political
system uh that right now the duopoly is
not
great for anybody
i hate it uh oh well even as the numbers
guy
i think the last numbers i saw 30
percent of americans
self-identified as democrats maybe 25
republicans and then 40 independents
and so you look up and say well that's
quite a quite a great deal of people
that
self-identify as independents and then
when it comes to this sort of election
everyone's like well you got these two
choices and you're like
like is it like how how quite did this
happen uh
again um so to to me the path forward
um is to have rank choice voting so that
there are just different points of view
reflected
and you don't have anyone bullying
anyone saying like can't waste your vote
can't waste your vote
now like it in this circumstance i'm i
like
you know everyone knows i'm for joe and
kamala and i think trump needs to go
um but i also think that the the fact
that we have
um we have so many americans who are
just like oh
like you know i i feel like my vote
doesn't matter because by the time it
gets to me i'm like
choosing between uh people that i would
not have chosen um
is not good for democracy it's not good
for the country
it's like that simpsons episode where
it's like uh
the two monster space monsters come and
land he goes we gotta pick from one of
us
one of us the republican one's democrat
and he goes i'm gonna vote third party
and he goes go ahead throw your vote
away and it's like and then the next
they're all enslaved in camps and it's
like it's the monsters rule the world
and it's
it's so heartbreaking because i know
that there's a lot of similarities on
both sides to where
that is that that middle ground that 40
of people who want something else
but tend to agree with 95 of
everything on the sides and all day long
we [ __ ]
and find these straw men of like this
fringe right or fringe left that we can
go see
they're all just like that and you know
and it's it's
it's disheartening because i've been
around a little bit and i've seen things
happen and i kind of know that it's a
show and a game and you're getting
things done and you're going
back and forth but young kids today who
are online all the time
think that twitter is real and this is
how it goes and this is life
and one it's not accurate that's like
five percent of the world is on twitter
and everyone else is doing real life
things
and if you just go i'm so mad at ben
shapiro right now and you go outside and
you're like
he has nothing to do with you gardening
in your backyard and it's but like folks
who have to
interact with groups of americans in
real life
in different parts of the country uh in
bars clubs wrestling arenas
autograph sessions it's like you have a
very different sense
of this country and of human beings
than uh just like turning on tv and
being like oh these people that people
because like you've actually met
thousands and thousands of people uh in
uh you know in in their everyday lives
and and then the caricatures don't
really stand up
i mean certainly i had that experience
running because like i met thousands and
thousands of people
like you yeah you i mean i'm somewhat
i've been around some people and bands
and stuff but you just like
two years ago like how does that you all
of a sudden
know five million people and you go oh
right people are for the most part
decent and want the same thing and want
to have a conversation
and how cool is it if you want to shake
your hand back when you're allowed to
shake hands
well you know i'm happy to say nick that
i kind of assumed that
most people were uh pretty reasonable
and just wanted the best things for
themselves and their family so it wasn't
like when i went out of the country i
discovered
it was more like i confirmed um what i
already knew
because i grew up in a town and like i
remember the kids i grew up with and
like
you know like did we do some dumb [ __ ]
that you know like if you were to paint
it now in like social media like you
know
like uh like would it look terrible sure
is that like are
those people are are those people
um somehow terrible human beings of
course not like you know we're just like
we're
like um you know [ __ ] teenage idiots
like
it was a different time we were lucky to
have that non-social media world and
non-camera world
and you have to do stupid stuff as a kid
and then the point is
you grow and then everybody wins
i and sometimes i feel that
people don't want you to grow they want
to make an example of something
and go oh you didn't atone for this
properly this thing you did 20 years ago
and you go ah it sucks
um but i did i'm talking to you right
now doesn't this count as me
growing up like no
yeah okay again people are so much more
reasonable in person than online
it's like like if you just stick two
people in a room it's like they would
not say
90 of like the nasty things that they'll
like put in a social media
post that's just not the way people are
they
they interact um so i get the sense
um from this conversation that if you
were to describe yourself politically it
would be
something of an independent where you
you see things uh
um in a non-partisan way is that
accurate uh yeah it's
very much so i go out of my way to do
that um i lean a little bit right
i like lower taxes i lean a little bit
right um
i i've done some stuff with fox and fox
business and
even the people on the left who've been
on panels with me like they're fantastic
they're so smart i love it
uh but i i lean a little bit right and
uh i
i uh but every issue i don't just go
down the line and go this is it and put
the yard sign out i want to
examine every issue and i feel like what
you mentioned
earlier there's that 40 of people who
have this
don't really totally relate to a party
but we want this general idea and
they're not really spoken to as much and
i i feel like there's that huge middle
and i
and i don't i'm an independent because i
hate every the two candidates that's not
the case
i just i lean right and uh i want
more people to meet in the middle and i
am very pro
third party let alone friggin 20 parties
just to give people some different
options you know
yeah i think the path to a third party
really is a different voting system like
rank choice voting because
you know it like it's it's a case where
the mechanics actually make a world of
difference like
if if you give people the ability to
vote their preference
uh and there's no there's no pressure to
you know again like
avoid quote-unquote wasting your vote
and the rest of it um
and the reality is that both party
registrations are actually declining
over time
you know like neither republicans nor
democrats are uh in growth positions
uh in that way and so to me like
if you're
if you're pro-democracy but also even if
you're pro these parties trying to
become more responsive to people
and maybe even resuming um like a growth
position
um then they need to try and engage with
different types of people and have
different types of ideas i mean that was
one of the reasons why i ran
um is that i thought the democratic
party could use
some new ideas uh including universal
basic income which
strikes me as not terribly um
left or right like it's just inevitable
i was gonna bring it up relax i know i
know the deal
well thank you nick look at that i could
do you think uh una oc in 2028 all this
stuff i have all these notes
no i i think that's that idea
shouldn't be i i don't want to sound
this wrong like it shouldn't be a crazy
idea to go
we can't try this thing where you don't
trust the government and you're sick of
them ruining your money we can't
trust the people with it just one time
and see what the hell happens like
we we we tried out trump like we wanted
an outsider why your idea should not be
a crazy idea
when we give we waste money in the
government so much
they mismanagement mismanage it a lot
and you go
let's give we you've met all these
people
you see that for the most part they're
good they want to do better
people some people are going to blow it
sure but that's life you know what i
mean give them a chance
because the government's going to blow
most of it anyway so let's get a shot
you know
yeah we just lived it too and people got
this 1200 stimulus check back in april
and i dare say it was awesome like
people people loved it
yeah i know people people like did what
they did um
but but but but by the numbers like
you know it worked like there was a
study that came out afterwards and
it made me laugh nick it was like like
giving people twelve hundred dollars
reduced poverty
and i was like yeah it it it really did
like great work so
so yeah like i think uh i mean right now
um something like 75 percent of
americans are pro cash relief during the
pandemic including majority of
republicans and democrats like
everyone's like look this is common
sense
yeah everyone's on board with us it just
seems like
the elections in coming up so we all
have to fight about if you can get 150
or 450
but nobody wants to lose points
politically which
this is that part of the game where it's
like guys
people are going to vote for trump or
biden how it's going to go
give these people a couple hundred
dollars for having to sit at home and
shut down their business
like come on thank you for listening in
i hope you enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you